so I'm Ryan and Elissa and we're gonna
watch the trailer for a new Disney movie
that's based on a Marvel comic what
that's what I heard at least I hope I
got that right
call big hero six does that even work
well Disney owns marble so get ready
yeah ooh that's kind of weird but
exciting that's pretty cool heavy not I
hope I got my facts right on this one
all right baby let's do this watch it
big
Sarah buddy
like Megaman like a fat Megaman Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh how cool that's pretty cool oh that's
awesome
I love the facepalm yeah okay it's
really cute at least boy look like an
ass let me just look it up real fast to
make sure it's part of our pop yes
adaptation of the Marvel comic ha I got
it right that's exciting I'm really
excited to see this that's cool to see a
Disney animated movie based on the
Marvel comic and even if it wasn't based
on Marvel comic I'd still check it out
it looks like a lot of fun definitely
made us laugh yeah and the creators of
frozen and wreck-it Ralph
that is awesome it is both of those
phones were amazing if you haven't seen
wreck-it Ralph you should because it's
amazing and I hope this is just as
amazing cuz it looks just as funny if
not funnier and I really want it as a
pet I feel like it'd be the best thing
ever
hiro hamada the robot companion okay ya
know this movie does look really [ __ ]
cool I mean it's a good teaser i watch
it just off that you know i don't need a
full trailer to go like yeah I'll check
this I'm sure is gonna be awesome [ __ ]
in this I want to know more like when it
comes out with a second trailer we
should go to be that one because I don't
know there's something about it like I
want to know more about the technology
in it
I want to more about the universe and
Sofia yeah how did you get it and what
is the context of it you don't know but
I want to know I want to know lots of
things to do can we make out now okay
well if you're new to the channel
subscribe yes please yeah whatever kid
Miguel with Oana subscribe to this is
true blues cruisin amok I don't be I'm
gonna call him Gump Eagles not via this
video I'm just really horny and you get
it out of my system okay grumpy feel
grumpy kills more like horny bills you
need to go to sleep you wait it's time
to do some shoutouts people shout out TF
for source you are the source of the TF
ores man good for you dude I'm proud of
you man gosh
that's impressive yeah dude this is
nobody people hold that position in the
world dude TF ores are like the most
awesome thing ever
yeah they they you know they've
developed over the years
they're third in the big leagues now
yeah they really made an impression
seriously what the [ __ ] is a TF
I thought I knew - I was counting on you
- no I didn't know I was just going
along with it anyway
Patrick nickels huh what's up dude this
guy's been wanting to shout out for a
while
oh wow that trick knee goes here's your
shutout whoa that was good
no was it huh trick nickel I tried you
come in an awful lot and I always read
your comments it's kind of like sleep
paragraphs really yes the best hope I
don't end up having to hold thousands of
conversation tie craft tie craft another
frequent comment sir they're nice I like
your craft oh I did you did there I was
sorry I got the bird I don't know why
did the bird for the west side
that's the west side what's I know I
don't want to do a gang symbol scare me
look like I did gain some buzz a joke
and then they literally took anything
serious yeah I felt like I find you dead
somewhere probably probably I'd have to
have Murray let me in and then and then
it'd be terrifying well that's why we
got to have sex before I die
next next
thank you doctor happy you're awesome
dude yeah seriously really appreciate
the support you've been giving to the
channel all you guys not just the three
we mentioned today but all you guys are
using you guys he has a really nice ssin
of this channel you're the ones who help
make this channel grow and flourish yeah
so continue like your videos and sharing
them be the seeds to our tree yes and uh
hello us on Facebook and Twitter
yeah all that fun [ __ ] cuz we have those
now we have those those people
recommended we get those so yes we want
to utilize them yes cuz although we have
them communication communication in case
like a whole other level with your fans
follow us everywhere everywhere
everywhere you can we have an insert
name follow it mm-hmm